SPEAKER 1: Well,
the biggest buzz
in education circles these days
is coming not from an educator,
but a one-time hedge fund
manager in Silicon Valley.
The former Ivy League whiz
kid has revolutionized
math instruction with a
series of online lessons
that have gone viral on YouTube.
Now as Elaine Korry
reports, his Khan Academy
is rocking California
classrooms.
ELAINE KORRY: It all
started a few years ago
when Sal Khan watched his
young cousin, Nadia, struggling
with her math homework.
He saw first hand
what he says is
wrong with math instruction
in America, a rigid model that
forces all students to
learn at the same pace.
SALMAN KHAN:
Obviously, the best way
to tutor them is
not to tell Nadia,
I'm going to teach you
exponents for 10 minutes,
even if you only understand
exponents halfway,
I'm going to move on to negative
exponents in the next 10
minutes.
ELAINE KORRY: Khan turned
that model on its head,
letting Nadia set her
own pace for learning.
He began posting little 10
minute math lessons online,
and the rest is history.
Today with 2,100 free tutorials,
the nonprofit Khan Academy
has the most popular education
website in the world.
And a pilot program
begun last fall
in Los Altos public
schools, is proof
that self-paced math instruction
can also work in the classroom.
CAMI THORDERSON: Good
morning, fifth grade.
Great to see you this morning.
I would remind you
that today we're
working on those fifth
grade goals in our classroom
on Khan Academy.
So let's get busy.
ELAINE KORRY: These 30 students
in Cami Thorderson's class,
are clustered in small
groups around laptops.
Key to this experiment,
the kids work together
helping each other to
solve math problems posted
on the Khan Academy website.
SPEAKER 2: So 2 is
x and 2 is also y.
So parenthesis first.
2 minus 1 equals 1.
Yay.
ELAINE KORRY: Andrew
and Ryan have already
mastered the fifth
grade curriculum,
so they've moved on to algebra.
After finishing some of
Khan's online modules,
they test their understanding
in a series of exercises.
SPEAKER 2: So you have
1 minus positive 3--
SPEAKER 3: Minus
3 is negative 2.
Negative 2 times 6.
SPEAKER 2: No, no, no.
Remember order of operations.
SPEAKER 3: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
ELAINE KORRY: Each
correct answer
earns them energy points.
Students compete
against each other
for the most points, which they
can redeem for cool badges.
SPEAKER 2: So like, moon
badges aren't too hard,
because I have a lot.
I have 227.
But it gets hard about
here, at the Earth badges.
ELAINE KORRY: While
the students are busy,
teacher Thorderson
wanders among them
with an electronic
tablet in hand.
It displays a customized
Khan Academy graph
showing in real time what
each child is working on.
Thorderson can zoom
in on any student
for a color coded
display of their work.
CAMI THORDERSON: The blues are
the problems he got correct.
The reds are the
problems he missed.
And I can actually
then go to him
and say, let's look at this
problem that you missed.
Let's work through
this a little bit.
ELAINE KORRY: After six months
with the Khan Academy program,
Thorderson is spending less
time grading tests or preparing
lectures, and more time
actually teaching one-on-one.
She's sold on the program.
CAMI THORDERSON: It's just
brought our math class
to a whole other level.
And you can hear the
excitement in the collaboration
that happens in this classroom.
They're talking to
each other about math.
They're just excited.
ELAINE KORRY: Some fifth
graders have surged ahead
and Khan Academy has helped
slower kids catch up.
The pilot program
in seventh grade
targeted Los Altos students
who had fallen several grade
levels behind.
Nearly all of them have
made good progress.
Parents also seem to
support the Khan Academy
and the students say they prefer
it to their old math class.
SPEAKER 2: It's not as boring
as writing in a textbook.
SPEAKER 3: Yeah, there's
different modules
so you can do whatever you want.
SPEAKER 4: And if we were doing
math in the textbook right now,
we wouldn't be
doing trigonometry.
ELAINE KORRY: The
Los Altos District
is working with
Khan to include up
to 1,000 students in
the program next fall.
Meanwhile, he's been scooping up
accolades, awards, and millions
of dollars in funding from the
Gates Foundation and Silicon
Valley backers.
Khan's been criticized
as a dilettante,
and dismissed as just another
quick fix for education,
but he doesn't care.
SALMAN KHAN: The
students, the teachers,
everyone is way more
engaged, and there's
reason to believe that
many of the students
are learning well ahead
of their grade level.
And I'm not talking about 10%
ahead, I'm talking about three,
four grade levels ahead.
ELAINE KORRY: By
September, Khan hopes
to have pilot programs in
a dozen school districts,
mostly in California.
For the California
report, I'm Elaine Korry.